the super bowl is this weekend the super
bowl's this weekend go rams you want the
rams because you lived in l.a who do you
know who's playing no are you a sports
guy do you know yeah yeah i wanted the
niners to win but now i don't care no
but i i want to see matt stafford get a
ring so yeah rams yeah you want the
right i would i i wouldn't be against
the other team it's the cincinnati
bengals thank you for the sheer luck
thank you for the
for the intro so
um you know everybody's trying to get
some rings right now this is what's
going on and i want you to pull this up
let me take a picture of this guy so the
quarterback for the other team
his name is joe burrow the other picture
please um his name is joe burrow
and he's got
it
whatever it is
homie's got okay this is a second year
in the league i believe he's got the
swag he won the heisman which was the
number one best college player he won
the national championship in college and
in his second year he's taken the
literally like the lowly cincinnati
bengals
to uh the super bowl and like
the the kids the kids got swagged it's
the iced up necklace okay that uh
which we're gonna address the the ice up
necklace so
i'm gonna read a quote and then i want
to get you guys thoughts on what this is
all comes down to so
uh the whole thing is that he has the it
factor or what they called irrational
confidence so
is this year two in the relationship
okay there it is so i want to date him
you don't even he's 22 by the way 24 by
the way this is a mad range yeah he's
older than 19. um so he once told a
reporter keep in mind he's a football
player she says how would you do if you
played an nba game keep in mind he's a
nfl guy coco i was just singing your
praises
um
he goes oh yeah i would have scored at
least 12 15 points not a big deal
straight face to camera like swagged out
and the reporter goes oh i knew this guy
was going to be a star just because of
his irrationality
i love that type of thing he's like i
got this thing he's got the it factor so
this was my question how important is it
for a man to just have that confidence
that that swag there's a song called
like bde that big dick energy you know
what i'm talking about right now from i
think lazzo um
what is confidence what does confidence
do for you he's the type of guy that
will like make reservations plan date
night like he's just so confident
he'll do it all
that's what confidence do make the plans
reservationally that's what confidence
does for you
for me like when a guy is confident i
feel
more protected because they're like
assertive in their choices and i
can kind of be undecisive at times so i
love guys like that okay
rebecca do you have strong feelings on a
confident man what does a confident
ambitious strong man do for you
i'll tell you a story
this was at a boat show a few years ago
it's in palm beach and i saw a man of no
idea who he was i was host this thing on
a boat and he was walking down the dock
and he had this white suit on
and he's walking just the way he walked
i had no idea who he was and i said i'll
know him i'll know him i'll know him
meaning like i'll meet him or it turns
out i don't know i'll know him
biblically i'll meet him i don't know i
don't know but i was like biblically
i'll know that man but i look at him i
was like okay that's my people all right
we've been friends ever since okay they
smashed so no
there was no sexual activity going on
there oh it was like really attractive i
have to crush on him for a long time but
it's um
no so what happened no just isn't he
gonna wait for
girl
he has many
he's got many yeah and we're just like
we're awesome friends but it's just like
it's that kind of thing and then when
you get to know the background of this
person why he walks like he does yeah so
when i see somebody i know how i am and
i get told that i'm scary and i'm
intimidating which is very funny for me
so i need somebody who can who is like
just really fully
in him or herself full alpha
i like alphas well you're pretty alpha
for a female i mean let's get real here
no doubt by the way so what's this guy's
deal give me his age his career his
thing you know what's he working with i
don't think anybody knows his age
best guess
what does he do where does he live he's
no like maybe 40.
maybe 50s okay i'm thinking okay he's
50s good looking i assume
owns the boat
works on the boat
you're not saying his name so please be
full disclosure you're not saying his
name so just absolutely not saying his
name no we don't want his name i have
jumbo i have no idea what he has because
that's not interesting to me but it's
probably a lot because of how other
people regard him but that's why we're
friends is because i don't care i just
like him for him because you said you've
had a crush on him so why are you
friends not a crush not like um not like
oh god i really nothing like that but
just like just really an admiration he's
like he's like the alpha man when other
people look they
aspire to be like him